our special correspondent Alex Crawford
is in Kiev for us right now hi Alex uh
what's happened
morning K morning everyone look at this
site the building's still smoking about
5 a.m this morning this huge residential
block was hit by a round of artillery
shells we're in the north of the the
city that's only seven miles from the
city center they're still trying to
retrieve their belongings we believe all
the people have been taken out we're not
sure about the injuries or the deaths
that this is quite clearly a residential
very much a residential area right in
the heart of a whole group of housing
right next to a school that's the
playground and the school next door to
it so this is absolutely nowhere near
anything that would constitute a
military Target the fire engines are
about five or six fire engines who've
been trying to get people out we've
spoken to some of the the residents
inside who one of whom said he had to
carry his 84 year old mother out to had
been cut from the you can see what it's
done to the building imagine if you're
inside that still sleeping as most
people would have been at five o'clock
this morning we've seen a number of the
the residents who once lived inside this
block going inside with um fire people
trying to gather up whatever they can
the few possessions that might still be
intact and looking inside these windows
you can see a glimpse of you know
ordinary people's lives who were just
sleeping there waking up to another
morning we know that this is the prize
for the Russians we know that the
Russian military sees capturing the
capital as key to their military plans
because the president has stayed here
the government is here and we've seen
over the past 48 24 48 hours that uh
there's someone else coming out there
just picking out picking up their um
their belongings and and coming out a
lot of these people still very much in
shock but still showing the resilience
that we've seen throughout this case
there you go someone else coming up and
this these are these scenes have been
unfolding for the past few hours and
um
I mean pretty heart-wrenching or you
know they're just grabbing whatever they
can in some cases it's food in some
cases bits of belongings sometimes just
clothes and being helped by soldiers and
civil defense and fire people I was
going on to say that we know that in in
Melissa poll we saw the capturing of the
the mayor which president zielinski sees
as um
is my mom do you speak English no a lot
of these people are still very much in
in shock and not wanting to talk we've
seen a number of them coming out crying
um but the man that we spoke to who was
happy to talk to us was extremely
defiant and saying that again
urging
um the International Community
particularly the West to help them more
with with weapons to help them with
closing the skies which they see is key
to turning this whole War
um Alex I'm sure you're aware story that
has developed within the last 20 minutes
or so about the image that we showed to
our viewers many of them will remember
from the Mario poll maternity hospital
this lady being carried out on a stretch
after that bombing of the hospital we
hear that the baby I can't believe the
story the baby has died during the
Caesarean section and mum has now also
died as well the Russians saying it's
fake news
oh that is absolutely tragic news we
know that I'm very sadly the Russian
military appears to be targeting places
like hospitals and schools the hospital
if you remember that we reported from a
couple of days ago right in the north
east of of Kiev I spoke to the doctor
overnight there you saw a number of
soldiers coming in there who who had
been hit they have withdrawn from that
hospital now and come further into the
center of the capital because the
hospital also came under attack and they
had to withdraw and shut down that
facility so I think there's no doubt
having spoken to the care chief of
police that they are mounting a dossier
which they intend to put forward to the
international criminal court in the hay
for them to investigate potential
walkouts but many of the ukrainians were
speaking to feel very strongly that
there are crimes against humanity and
war crimes being committed is on a daily
base here and certainly those inside the
capital are feeling much more
nervous but incredibly defiant every day
every true throughout the day they're
not wasting any time by building up
barricades and and trying to reinforce
um the capital but the the Russian
military and the the advance of the
Russian military is is edging ever
closer to the center okay Alex just
before I let you go give me the
geography of of where you are again for
viewers obviously tuning our way all the
time where are you and what's happened
sure
sure we're in the north of the city
we're only seven miles from the center
it's a big sprawling City and if you
take this the center to be um for
instance where the Saints of your
Cathedral is say we're seven miles north
of that so really a hop skip and a jump
we're we're in the city the city area if
you like Kiev also has a wider region
like greater London has we're inside
that wider region so we're seven miles
from the center due due north it's a
district called Avalon we're really
right in this is residential area this
is a huge residential Block it's right
next to a school and playing fields
there's no way anyone could have mistook
this for a military Target
Alex thanks very much indeed for the
update thank you